kim kardashian and pete davidson are all
smiles on vacay soaking up a little fun
under the sun
yes
on wednesday kim and pete who we're
officially dubbing keat were snapped on
a dock after taking a boat ride together
in the bahamas that's the 41 year old
kkw beauty founder rocking dark shades a
plunging low-cut black top with black
ripped jeans and heels which she
accessorized with a black fuzzy purse
and that right there that's the 28 year
old saturday night live star sporting a
beige hoodie and matching shorts with a
navy jacket and socks with slides i love
that of course kim and pete's boat ride
comes after the two were spotted
boarding a private plane earlier this
week a source at the time told et that
the two weren't able to spend new year's
eve together kim was in california with
her family while pete was hosting his
new year's eve special with miley cyrus
in miami
miley's going to be performing some of
her favorite songs tonight
and i'll be here also and since they
have a busy couple of months of work
ahead of them they wanted to take some
time away together before the year ramps
up and from the looks of it the two are
having a blast it's really lit and fun
and crazy in fact on thursday kim shared
this bikini snap on instagram alongside
the caption
sweet sweet fantasy i love that energy
in my life still neither kim nor pete
have publicly confirmed their
relationship and their friends and
family are staying tight-lipped too oh
boy on new year's eve kim's mom kris
jenner was a virtual guest on andy cohen
and anderson cooper's new year's eve
special on cnn and the momager perfectly
sidestepped a question about her
daughter's romance with a little help
from kylie jenner's three-year-old
daughter stormy you know everyone is
talking about kim's new relationship
with pete davidson if you had the chance
to spend time with them how are they as
a couple you're always digging in yes i
am
i know you have a visitor
i know she
that's a little stormy um
hey stormy oh
um you sit right here um yeah
nice distraction good timing stormy
and when e.t caught up with the
comedian's snl co-star alex moffitt he
played coy when asked about the couple
i don't really stay up to date with what
my good friend pete's up to as long as
he's having fun and he's happy that's
all i care about he's a love
then there's machine gun kelly who's
super close with pete he straight up
dodged questions about the pair with an
official no comment
gotta ask you your boy pete davidson and
kim kardashian how happy are you for him
but we're happy yeah yeah
and while no one's officially commenting
on kim and pete's love these bahamas
smiles say it all at the end of the day
life is about being happy
of course the two first sparked romance
rumors back in october after kim's
hosting gig on snl
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you going to kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
and if that onscreen kiss wasn't enough
to get people talking this snap of them
holding hands on a roller coaster later
that month had the internet on fire and
ever since the two have been spotted
together in la new york and palm springs
it's always so much fun so just how
serious is it a source previously told
et the two are dating and having a great
time together quote pete is a romantic
and goes out of his way to make kim feel
special kim thinks pete is hysterical
and he's constantly making her laugh but
they also have been connecting on a
deeper level
[Music]